angel über die schulter und los street
phishing heißt das neue hobby vieler
junger großstädter
seinen ursprung hat der sport
wahrscheinlich in paris doch
mittlerweile ist street phishing in ganz
europa beliebt victorias ist gerne in
berlin unterwegs
[Musik]
und ich angehe dann kann ich eigentlich
super abschalten vom alltag man vergisst
so alle probleme um einen herum
zwei bis drei mal pro woche wird der 37
jährige die angel aus einer seiner
lieblings potts die umfang brücke in
berlin mitte viele leute glauben dass
man statt überhaupt gar keine frische
gibt aber das natürlich ein irrglaube
weil es gibt richtig richtig viele
fische vor allem zander barsche sind
alles tolle fischen die man angehen kann
das ist ein barsch gibt's hier relativ
häufig aber noch viel größer hoffentlich
deswegen daher ausnahmsweise heute
schwimmt
das gibt natürlich auch größere branche
oder auch größere andere fische wie
zander die man dann auch super essen
kann
denn die wasserqualität der berliner
flüsse ist besser als viele annehmen
auch stars sind begeisterte angler sowie
der brite david beckham mit seinen
söhnen der deutsche ex fußball
nationalspieler miroslav klose und der
spanische tennisspieler rafael nadal vor
allem die junge generation macht die
stadt zu ihrem angelplatz max morawski
ist 22 jahre alt muss cool 15
verschenken ist das ja man kann einfach
nach der arbeit so wie heute noch mal
schnell ans wasser fahren und hat keinen
großen aufwand kann sich eine route
nehmen köder und dann einfach loslegen
mehr ausrüstung braucht man zum street
phishing also nicht hauptsache sie ist
ultraleicht denn wenn der stadt an den
möchte muss mobil sein
auch im internet das thema viele
youtuber geben ihre erfahrungen in
videos weiter 30 grad im schatten
eigentlich muss man bahn gehen aber ich
will trotzdem anderen gehen mit mehr als
130.000 abonnenten und 27 millionen
aufrufen betreibt victorias einen der
erfolgreichsten deutschen angel
youtube-kanäle seit 2013 kann man ihn
dort bei ausflügen begleiten
ich glaube warum man kann also
erfolgreich ist ist deswegen so dass es
sich nur um es anderen geht sondern dass
wir immer so eine kleine story haben und
immer ein bisschen was passiert und der
unterschied zum fernsehen prinzipiell
bei youtube ist eben das ist echt ist
die leute mögen es wenn es echt ist und
deswegen glaube ich gucken so gern auf
diese videos
[Musik]
rund fünf millionen hobby angler gibt es
in deutschland und jedes jahr werden es
mehr
auch mit den angler verbänden ist der
trend spürbar
seit einigen jahren steigen die
mitgliederzahlen stetig
meiner meinung nach sehr vielfältig zum
einen wollen viele junge menschen auch
wieder so ein bisschen zurück zur natur
wieder natur abenteuer erleben
auf der anderen seite ist es auch so
dass zum beispiel in heutigen zeit
youtube kanäle über das angeln vorhanden
sind bei dem angeln einfach ein komplett
entstaubt das image bekommt vor angeln
als sehr cool dargestellt wird street
phishing ein angelsport jung und modern
auch das outfit ist lässig typische an
der westen und wathosen sucht man
vergeblich kurze hosen t shirts und
baseball caps sind angesagt alle länder
statt auf jeden fall wesentlich sozialer
als wenn man irgendwo alleine auf dem
see sitzt oder andere sitzt es ist cool
man kann sich überall was zu essen was
zu trinken holen und wenn andere leute
einfach so am wasser sitzen sitzt man
halt mit freunden und anhalt einfach
dabei noch ein bisschen
street phishing mitten in der großstadt
die neue auszeit vor der haustür
[Musik]